spoiler warning this episode is
neck-deep and spoilers for The Last of
Us
BioShock Infinite and hotline Miami
seriously we talk about endings twists
metaphors and things with the assumption
that you guys have played the game or
don't care you have been warned
hold on to your asses I'm going to say
something super controversial here we
like violence in our video games and our
movies and our sports and our television
and our rock and roll all right we're
pretty much fans of violence all around
but few forms of media are as saturated
with violence as video games often are
there's a few reasons for that and well
you know what let's yeah let's discuss
that real quick it's it's some good
context why is violence so prevalent in
video games well number one the simple
answer is that it's an easy source of
conflict and drama
these demons want to kill you so you
kill them first or well I guess that's
the 90s version these brown people want
to kill you so you kill them first I
guess I should get it out there that I'm
not opposed to violent media but I'm
also not going to sit here and pretend
that there aren't any problems
associated with it as gameplay number
two it holds up fairly well to
repetition which is pretty important
since most games are ultimately really
repetitive this doesn't mean that it
doesn't get repetitive it just means
that there's a higher threshold before
half your players get bored and walk
away lastly it provides the novelty of
exploring transgressive or permissive
scenarios society doesn't really
tolerate punching people as a method of
problem solving because well it doesn't
really work that well and to turn
society into a bit of a crap hole but we
still have that lizard brain impulse
that wants us to strangle the [ __ ]
who cuts us off in traffic violent games
let us indulge in that aggression in a
comparatively harmless controlled
environment now I don't want that to
sound like a justification or dismissal
of violent media simply because there
are reasons for something to be the way
it is doesn't make that a good thing
just because we have a craving for
violence doesn't mean it's not something
we shouldn't be critical of if anything
cravings indicate things we should be
most critical of because they're the
ones that are most likely to get out of
trol moving on you really don't have to
go very far to find a game that is
driven by careless nigh indiscriminate
violence but that's not what I want to
talk about how far do you have to go to
find a game driven by violence that uses
that violence to drive a point in
essence how hard is it to find a game
where the violence itself is part of the
narrative themes and metaphor and not
just the expression of the conflict or
the gameplay well actually not that far
these days while there's still tons of
games out there that are simply violent
if not reveling in that violence there
is a surprising number of games that
have started to incorporate it into the
narrative in order to communicate
something about the characters the world
the story or the interactions between
those elements many of them are at the
same time using that violent aspect of
the narrative to ask questions about the
game itself the genre and the audience
or simply challenging the audience's
complicit participation so let's talk
about it
you
the number of confirmed deaths has
passed 200 the last of us follows the
story of Joel and Ellie two survivors in
a post-apocalyptic world where the
cordyceps fungus has made the leap from
arthropods and insects to humans with
social systems on the fritz and the
persistent threat of infection and
infected it's everyone for themselves as
the to trek west from boston to salt
lake in pursuit of an organization
called the fireflies who hope to develop
a vaccine from Ellie who is immune to
the fungus on this journey
Joel stabbed strangled shoots burns curb
stomps and explodes basically every
living thing that the two encounter even
the few people that aren't hostile
towards them Joel threatens to kill if
they get in his way
in the end Ellie nearly drowns but the
two are rescued / captured by the
fireflies an unconscious Ellie is rushed
into surgery while Joel discovers that
they plan on discectomy Lee's brain to
try and develop their vaccine at this
point the blunt brutal violence of the
game transcends from game mechanic to
character element Joel goes on a rampage
killing everyone he comes across because
that's all he knows how to do after a
life of violence violence is the only
tool Joel has left as the game winds
down we realize that we have been
playing in the skin as a borderline
psychopath this is actually the payoff
of a theme established several times
earlier in the game near the beginning
tests Joel's partner in crime alludes to
the horrible things they've done and
reminds Joel hood they're not the good
guys around the midpoint after Joel and
Ellie are waylaid by bandits we learned
that Joel knows all of their tricks
because he used to be one of them after
his rampage at the hospital Joel kidnaps
Ellie and lies to her about what
happened while she was unconscious in
the final moments of the game the player
assumes control of Elliot is given a
chance to look at Joel objectively not
as the player avatar but as a shallow
shattered person a man so broken so
narrowed in vision that the only
instinct he has left is kill or be
killed the preceding 15 hours of
gameplay are recontextualized not as
expression of the players agency but the
player buying into Joel's narrow
simplistic desperate and selfish
worldview and the final beat is not
Joel's vision of victory but the
uncertain and uncomfortable
act that so-called victory has had on
the world around him okay
oh hey there welcome to bathroom
vocabulary the reason why it's so
important for the players control to
shift from Joel to Ellie is because of
attentional bias or as TV Tropes refers
to a protagonist centered morality this
is in essence the tyranny of the
narrator and is incredibly common in
video games because of the agency we
imbue the player character with is
incredibly easy for us to slip into a
mindset where whatever the protagonist
does is immediately justifiable because
of the way that we empathize with their
world view even if objective data
suggests that the protagonist behavior
is undesirable
while the arc of BioShock Infinite
doesn't follow the same path as the Last
of Us it uses its violence in much the
same way the game has actually received
a fair bit of criticism for its
brutality which often seems out of place
against the backdrop of Columbia
compared to the pastoral and often
cartoon look of the world ended the
characters but could you wit driving a
skyhook through someone's eye seems like
unnecessarily brutal imagery but like
The Last of Us this excess is an
expression of the character and his
impact on the world around him like joy
Booker is a violent man who has lived a
life of chaos first in the Army at the
massacre of Wounded Knee then as a
union-busting Pinkerton Booker's life
has been killing and violence as all he
knows his role in Colombia is as a
bringer of violence a sower of chaos and
his unashamed brutality sets in motion a
cascade of pain and destruction this
role as a bringer of destruction as a
tool for violence is actually something
Booker knows about himself in one
conversation Booker says the world needs
revolutionaries like Fitzroy because of
people like himself because of folks
like me this is in many ways an overt
theme of the first half of the game from
Elizabeth's shock and horror over the
massacre at battleship Bay leading up to
Elizabeth killing Fitzroy it's actually
a fairly critical arc in the game as it
is then mirrored in the second half as
the story unravels with its multiple
timelines and alternate realities it's
revealed that the main antagonist is a
Currie Comstock a warlord using religion
and patriotism as justification for his
campaign of conquest is in fact Booker
from an alternate timeline and Elizabeth
is Booker's daughter taken through a
tear in reality and raised by Comstock
in the first half of the game Booker
slowly unintentionally transforms
Elizabeth into a killer at one point she
asks Booker if the killing gets easy and
he responds by saying yes it does faster
than you would ever imagine in the
second half of the game Elizabeth is
captured by Comstock tortured and molded
until she becomes a conquering warlord
in his own image raining fire down on
New York indeed as Booker said the
killing got easy
earlier I said that Booker's brutality
seems out of place against the backdrop
of Columbia but that that was a bluff
the player learns fairly quickly that
the idyllic setting is just a facade
that Comstock's utopia is founded on
spiritual violence racism segregation
oppression exploitation and the
suppression read murder of political
opposition while Comstock is not the
only problem on Columbia it is his
personal willingness to use violence as
a solution to his problems that is at
the core of most of the conflicts he had
the loot s's murdered he imprisoned
Elizabeth he killed lady Comstock and he
framed Fitzroy for the crime Fitzroy's
excesses are the product of Fink and
Comstock successes and the wheel of
violence and justification continues to
turn in the conclusion were led to
believe that it is Booker himself who is
the problem that whether he be DeWitt or
Comstock he will still carry violence
and brutality in his heart and he will
pass that brutality onto his daughter
and he will inflict it on the world
around him the critical moment in the
narrative is a baptism that Booker seeks
out in a haze of regret over his role in
the massacre of Wounded Knee in one
timeline he rejects the baptism at the
last second resigns himself to the life
of a monster joins the Pinkertons slips
into alcohol and gambling and sells his
daughter to a strange man from another
world in the other timeline he is reborn
as Zachary Comstock but rather than
renouncing his past deeds he rewrites
them not as shameful acts of terror but
as righteous Valerie across infinite
universes there will always be a Booker
desperate enough to sell his daughter
and there will always be a Comstock
ambitious enough to buy her the only way
to break the chain is for there to be no
more Booker she Sakura cost
just bucket away
incidentally just to take this all the
way it's implied in a sequence
post-credits that the willingness to die
in his second baptism the acceptance of
his own unworthiness and his lack of a
place in a just world was the in fact
indicative of a true change of heart and
character and that act did break the
chain this one this one's special
hotline Miami is an incredibly violent
game not just violence but saturated
violence the game is almost wall-to-wall
chopping bashing shooting slamming
crushing and slicing but it does several
very interesting things with this
seemingly wanton violence
first is the backtracking now slight
side note but I feel like it drives home
why this is interesting
backtracking going back through areas
that have already been completed or even
just areas that the player has passed
through before has become something of a
dirty word in video games to the point
that many games avoid it to their own
detriment so it's already somewhat
unique that hotline Miami uses
backtracking in the first place and they
managed to use it to great effect every
level of hotline Miami consists of a
confined space that the player fights
their way into until they've killed
every opponent present however once the
task is complete the player has to
backtrack through the level and return
to their car there's rarely any
opponents that show up during these
sequences so presumably these are just
dead space in the game an irrelevant and
redundant action that poses no challenge
and has no relevance to the outcome of
the game except this creates a moment
where the player navigates through the
carnage they've left behind absent any
threat rather than focusing on the
gameplay of navigating to the next
opponent in killing them the player is
instead left to absorb the big picture
of the horror show they're creating this
uneasiness is
amplified as the player learns during
cutscenes between missions that the main
characters motivations are spurious at
best
in fact the nameless protagonist seems
to ask disturbingly few questions about
what's going on and why even after he
stops being rewarded for his massacres
the game criticizes the characters
complicit participation in the violence
which in turn criticizes the players
willingness to act without asking
questions early on the game presents a
number of unanswered questions that
intentionally blur the line between
being directed at the character and
being directed at the player the first
of these questions is do you enjoy
hurting others at the end of the game
incidentally after the credits which is
a bit of an odd theme here but anyway
after the credits you're given the
chance to play an alternate
interpretation of events as the biker in
contrast to jacket who asks no questions
just does what he's asked biker asks a
lot of questions and this is the only
segment of the game where the player is
given the option of leaving people alive
these are hardly the only examples in
recent memory spec ops the line Far Cry
3 Tomb Raider and heavy rain have all in
one capacity or another applied a
critical eye to violence in video games
whether it be exploring the impact of
violence on the characters themselves
the overuse of violence for cheap drama
and conflict or the audience is
seemingly endless thirst for guns and
explosions heavy rain does more with a
single bullet than other games manage
with thousands of rounds I'm a father
too I think this is an interesting trend
because it shows a maturing palette for
critical narrative and video game
stories which is a good thing because
video games through their interactive
nature allow us to explore some subjects
like agency and interaction in far more
potent ways than cinema books comics or
television there's still a place for
your Mortal Kombat's and Borderlands
tools but it's refreshing to see so many
creators doing more than just telling
the story of that time Johnny Cage
plunged Kano in the deck
we're going to end this on a bit of a
philosophical note a question to think
about these games are in some form or
another critical of their own violence
but can a game truly be critical of its
own violence if it still expects you to
play through beginning to end in order
to get the whole message is there a
dichotomy in that and is that dichotomy
a contradiction
and there's another really loud part big
ol fat truck yeah you take a fat truck
and keep on driving all right it was the
same